[Música]
en Colombia los diálogos de paz con la
guerrilla del elnpen de un hilo por
cuenta de un atentado este jueves que
dejó nueve militares fallecidos y otros
nueve heridos en la zona del catatumbo o
vecina de Venezuela el ataque efectuado
por el grupo ilegal trae muchas
preguntas que vamos a responder con
Camilo González pozo quien es el
presidente del instituto de estudios
para el desarrollo y la Paz inde Paz
Camilo Bienvenido a directo a América y
gracias por estar con nosotros
muy complacido estar acá en varias
oportunidades ya hemos consultado con
ustedes sobre temas como este ahora
Quiero preguntarle específicamente sobre
la acción de Gustavo Petro porque de las
decisiones que toma el presidente
dependerá entre otras cosas la confianza
de las fuerzas armadas del país que
esperan o que exigirían los militares en
este contexto
Pues la verdad que sabe este golpe que
ha dado el eln es un algo que perturba
muchísimo
daña el ambiente de para las
conversaciones de paz y también pues
pone una alerta para las fuerzas
militares porque pues como estas
acciones se pueden repetir las
situaciones más grave porque el
presidente en repetidas ocasiones ha
planteado primero un cese unilateral al
Ln para iniciar conversaciones pero no
tuvo ninguna respuesta luego en vísperas
de las conversaciones en México el
presidente habló que uses de cualquier
agresión a la población civil de una ley
humanitario y de trabajar el esencia del
fuego como un asunto prioritario sin
embargo el eln no le ha dado ninguna
importancia por el contrario hablan un
lenguaje de entendimiento con el
gobierno de de propósito de ese escalar
pero en la práctica está incrementando
las confrontaciones atentados a los
productos
y ese doble lenguaje pues está generando
mucho problema en el manejo de esta mesa
de conversaciones lo que se ha anunciado
es una rectificación un planteamiento
nuevo así lo ha dicho El Vocero de la
delegación notipatiño quien ha planteado
que su postura para la reunión del lunes
será proponer que se considere en
primera instancia el tema de alivio
humanitario se hace hostilidades y de
cese al fuego es decir las posibilidades
de que las mesas Se se suspenda están
está en el aire si el eln insiste en
declarar al gobierno de Petro como
enemigo y objetivo militar no Y además
con argumentos como los que hemos
escuchado de algunos de sus Voceros que
califican que el presidente Petro es el
responsable de los ataques que grupos
armados le hacen en sus territorios
porque califican que Son estructuras
paramilitares auxiliadas por el ejército
no y entre tanto crecen las voces que se
desde la campaña en las que se decía que
Gustavo Petro estaba debilitando a las
fuerzas armadas pero bien Vamos a las
declaraciones de otti Patiño y este
pedido de que la prioridad absoluta sea
exigir el alto el fuego como usted nos
ha venido diciendo ahora le pregunto
esto es realista que se logre ese alto
el fuego como prioridad para que las
condiciones se den para un diálogo
continuado sí sí sí sí sí pues en
Colombia se han hecho diálogos en medio
de confrontaciones de no sé si al fuego
Pero hay una situación nueva un ambiente
político en Colombia y si lo que se
quiere es un acuerdo nacional y una
participación de la sociedad pues es un
absurdo invitar a a la gente a una
comunidad o a diferentes actores a un
diálogo para buscar reformas y cambios
en el país y al mismo tiempo estar
colocando haciendo atentados o
diciendo que en cualquier momento puede
haber una acción militar
es completamente antagónico
el propiciar una participación para el
cambio y la continuidad de acciones
armadas el propio LG ha dicho que
considera que está en una nueva
coyuntura que hay un gobierno de
izquierda algunos de ellos han dicho que
hay puntos de coincidencia en el
lenguaje de cambio no Y entonces por qué
le declararon la guerra al gobierno de
Petro yo creo que puede sonar un poquito
fuerte decir que le han declarado la
guerra pero es que lo que están diciendo
es que van a continuar haciendo ese tipo
de acciones y hemos tenido el
pronunciamiento de algunos no no todos
pero de frentes vamos a ver si se
confirma al frente occidental y de
algunos de frente Oriental donde
definitivamente ahí si no se entiende
para dónde van No claro y Es que además
el eln se ha caracterizado por ser
reconocido como un grupo que sobre todo
en los últimos años ha estado muy
fragmentado no entonces uno no sabe de
dónde vienen los objetivos de los
frentes del eln y sobre eso le quería
hablar porque esta mañana surge la
noticia de la declaración del frente
occidental que dice que no está a gusto
con la forma en que se están
desarrollando estos diálogos enmarcados
en La Paz total y reiteran esto que
usted nos decía de la denuncia de que se
abre el espacio para el paramilitarismo
en el país consensuado o permitido por
el gobierno y que ellos quieren que los
diálogos vayan en otra dirección porque
así como están las cosas Pues no están
dispuestos a este cese de hostilidades
en qué dirección cree usted que tendrían
que ir los diálogos o más bien dónde
está el punto de consenso para que se
puedan adelantar
Pues la verdad que el punto de consenso
tiene que ser la expresión de las partes
y del caso del eln de que la hipótesis
principal durante estos próximos dos
años es llegar a un acuerdo de paz y
determinación del alzamiento armado es
lo que ha garantizado que en otras
ocasiones se llegue a algún resultado es
que los grupos armados al entrar Ya
dicen nuestra disposición y nuestra
hipótesis es que vamos a la dejación de
la lucha armada en cambio el Ln dice
todo lo contrario nuestra hipótesis es
que con este gobierno no vamos a dejarla
luchar para decir no es tan maduros para
dejar la lucha armada Ese es el gran
problema ahora ahí hay ese proceso es
Dinámico porque uno escucha voces voces
de algunos comandantes en el caso del
mismo modo de Pablo Beltrán pero también
de gente cercana al Ln en regiones donde
ellos tienen influencia
dicen Está bueno de guerra hay que
terminar las armas para hacer los
cambios que es también la tesis del
gobierno hay gente dentro del Elena que
dice tenemos que hacer una vigilancia
Armada hasta que no se hagan las
reformas de fondo y las reformas de
fondo dicen es cambiar la democracia
representativa por la democracia
participativa directa y cambiar el
capitalismo por el socialismo Entonces
si van a estar en armas vigilando la
revolución Pues la verdad que por ese
camino no van a llegar a una negociación
con este gobierno Entonces lo primero es
que el eln tiene que hacer un
replanteamiento ellos no han decidido
negociar todavía su último congreso que
se hizo
en gobierno anteriores dijo vamos a a
conversar pero para explorar no para
negociar Ahora hay un nuevo gobierno una
nueva circunstancia estamos en la
posibilidad realmente de
transformaciones de cambio y con la
vieja política entonces tiene que haber
una rectificación y ese eso es lo que
espera el país que se dé una discusión
interna que las bases sociales donde
ellos están les digan bueno permitan que
tengamos unas experiencias de inversión
unos territorios de paz un alivio un
cese al fuego pero Camilo por un lado
pues han criticado el llamado gobierno
del cambio han dicho que no ha cumplido
sus promesas y que en esto se basan
también para no ahondar en diálogos más
profundos entre tanto sorprende que con
toda esta crisis que usted nos describe
el presidente haya decidido citar a sus
negociadores para dentro de cinco días y
no hacer una reunión inmediata por un
lado eso y por otro lado ya para
finalizar rápidamente es que recordemos
que un atentado paró las negociaciones
que llevaba el gobierno de Iván Duque
anteriormente Entonces estamos a puertos
de que esto vuelva a pasar pues bueno de
todas maneras el gobierno de Iván Duque
Había decidido que
cerrarle la puerta a toda con las
guerrillas o cualquier intento de
solución negociada mediante pactos de
transformaciones de paz eso fue su línea
y por eso básicamente lo que hizo el
elenes va a ayudarle a a Duque a cerrar
la puerta porque ya esa eso ya era una
decisión ahora Estamos al contrario es
un gobierno que está diciendo
convocamos a todos Incluyendo a ustedes
señores que están en armas a quien
unamos esfuerzos para ser grandes
transformaciones en Colombia Esa es la
hora de terminar
60 años de guerras eso no quiere decir
hay gente que confunde la paz total con
la ausencia de toda violencia y toda
criminalidad no la pastoral es cerrar un
período de guerras en Colombia de uso de
las armas en la política y para las
reformas y abrir un período de
alternancia democrática de juego de
transformaciones mediante la lucha
política legal lo que Camilo tampoco
Será posible en apenas un mandato y ya
para el cierre Pues en Twitter uno uno
no entiende porque el presidente de que
está en tuitero dijo que están muy lejos
de las negociaciones muy lejos de las
intenciones de paz Así que bueno
quedamos en completa incertidumbre esa
de Camilo González pozo presidente del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz Gracias a usted bueno Muchas
gracias y nuestros televidentes sigan
con nosotros ya volvemos con más de
titulares de directo a América
[Música]